élu en mai dernier à la mairie le jeune
édile novice en politique a découvert
l'état des finances de sa commune et la
situation n'est pas brillante pour cette
commune on a un budget qui tourne
annuellement autour des 200 milles euros
et on a énormément de travaux à prévoir
la situation actuelle est que nous avons
quatre emprunts sur le dos pour un
montant global de 101 milles euros
grosso modo la commune est endettée
jusqu'en 2035
mais le maire ne rejette pas la faute
sur les équipes municipales précédentes
l'agrandissement du cimetière et des
travaux de voirie ont obligé la commune
à s'endetter mais voilà d'autres
dépenses vont s'imposer
le maire n'a pas de solution pour les
financer il a même dû lancer une
cagnotte sur internet
alors en fait on a une des plus belles
églises du brionnais et cette église
nécessite des travaux de restauration
extrêmement importants qui sont estimé
aujourd'hui à environ un million deux
cent mille euros et sur cette somme il
faut que la mairie qui est maître
d'ouvragé accompagné très près par
l'association de sauvegarde de l'église
doit trouver environ 400000 euros
cette tension financière touche de
nombreuses petites communes du
département avec des magistrats qui
souvent n'osent pas demander de l'aide
mais des solutions existent selon
l'association des maires ruraux qui ne
juge pas cette situation catastrophique
quand un collègue maire est en
difficulté nous le conseille quant lui
donne c'est un d'aller voir le sous
préfet ou le préfet et puis 2 bat notre
association l'association des maires
ruraux est là aussi pour ça pour
échanger entre pairs pour discuter de
nos difficultés est toujours utile de
bénéficier de l'expérience des collègues
pour l'instant le maire de varennes
l'arconce ne se voient proposer qu'une
fusion avec d'autres communes par la
sous-préfecture ses espoirs se tournent
désormais vers les conseils des autres
maires ruraux du département